The stage set for the Andrew File System, AFS, is
the CMU campus. And the user community can access
file servers using workstations connected to a local
area network. And as I mentioned, local disks on the
workstation served as efficient caches. And the vision of the designers
of the Andrew File System and the Coda file system, both of which were built
at CMU for enabling the student community to
access a central file system, is as follows.
A user walks up to any workstation and, and logs into the work station. And your
content magically appears on this workstation from the
central server as soon as you log in.
In other words, in the CMU experiment, what they wanted to afford the users
to be able to do is have this ability to walk up
to any workstation spread out throughout the campus and be able to
access their personal information that is stored
in servers that are central to the entire campus. Isn't that what
today's cloud computing and mobile devices are trying to do to your
content? In some sense you'll see that many of the technologies that
we take for granted today had their modest beginnings in
experiments such as the Andrew File System and the Coda file system at CMU.